NHS Hospital Darlington Memorial in
County Durham gave a form an outpatient
survey to a woman in her 70s which
offered 18 gender options musically male
and female okay good so far non-binary
third gender transgender man transgender
woman transgender two-spirit bigender
which sounds like a whole thing
altogether big Ender I wouldn't mind
identifying as that gender expression
gender oh it's by gender apparently
sorry I thought it said big Ender
genderqueer passing agenda cisgender I
think that's me I never quite worked out
why I have to be a uh gender fluid
and gender it's a story in the sun
tomorrow uh Esther when you see the
stuff given to a woman in her 70s who
identifies for the purposes of of
clarity as a woman
this is nuts what are we doing what's
the NHS doing whether this was a mental
like mental health output because what
does your gender identity have to do
with your biology